a very similar kind of uh
empowering aspect of the drake equation
is
say that there is a huge number of
intelligent civilizations that spring up
everywhere
but because of the drake equation which
is the lifetime of a civilization
yeah maybe many of them hit a wall and
yeah
and just like you said it's clear that
that for us
the great filter the one possible great
filter seems to be coming
you know in the next 100 years so it's
also empowering to
say okay well uh
we have a chance to not i mean the way
great filters work it does
get most of them exactly nick bostrom
has
articulated this really beautifully too
i i you know every time
yet another search for life on mars
comes back negative or something i'm
like yes
are odds for us surviving yes
you already made the argument that
brought rush there right
but just unpack it right the point is we
already know
there's a crap ton of planets out there
that are earth-like and we also know
that
most of them do not seem to have
anything like our kind of life on them
so
what went wrong there's clearly one step
along the evolutionary at least one
filter roadblock in going from no life
to space-faring life and um
where is it is it in front of us or is
it behind us
right if if there's no filter behind us
and we keep finding all sorts of of uh
little mice on mars and or whatever
right
that's actually very depressing because
that makes it much more likely that the
filter is in front of us
and that what actually is going on is
like the ultimate
dark joke that that whenever a
civilization
invents sufficiently powerful tech it's
just you just set your clock and then
after a while it goes poof
for one reason or other and and wipes
itself out that will be wouldn't that be
like utterly depressing
if we're actually doomed whereas if it
turns out
that there is a really there is a great
filter early on
that for whatever reason seems to be
really hard to get to the stage of um
sexually reproducing organisms or even
the first
ribosome or whatever right or
or maybe you have lots of planets with
dinosaurs and cows but for some reason
they tend to get stuck there and never
invent smartphones
all of those are huge vic boosts for our
own odds
because been there done that you know
it doesn't matter how hard it or
unlikely it was that we got past that
roadblock because we already did yeah
and
then then that makes it likely that the
future is in our own hands we're not
doomed so that that's why that's why i
think
the fact that like that the life is rare
in the universe it's not just something
that there's some evidence for
but also something we should actually
hope for
you